(ambient music)
We all have the opportunity to choose
our sovereign connection to our spiritual nature.
It's about getting into your pure basic awareness.
There is some bedrock of love, an alterable love,
that is the truth of who we are.
It's not just darkness,
it doesn't just end, we continue.
We have physical fitness for the physical core,
we need spiritual fitness for the spiritual court.
You need a practice without devices
where you can be a peace.
Regardless of who you talk to, Doctors, theologians,
therapists, researchers, or even addicts,
the collective wisdom of various disciplines all agree,
a spiritual practice of some kind, any kind,
is essential to human growth and flourishing.
So in this, our sixth masterclass,
my team and I have compiled a variety of helpful clips
on spirituality from a variety of past guests
in the hope that you may glean essential wisdom,
new perspectives, and some concrete practices
that can add value to your daily life.
Whether you're already part of a rich spiritual tradition
or perhaps you're somebody who's just beginning
to seek a spiritual path,
I think the following clips can help all of us
better understand the importance of spirituality
to our overall health and wellbeing.
And we began with Dr. Lisa Miller,
a leading generational psychologist
on the benefits of spirituality.
Lisa is a professor of psychology and education
at Teachers College Columbia University
and is the founder and director
of the Spirituality Mind Body Institute.
In this clip, Lisa unpacks the recent neuroscience research
that establishes that humans are universally equipped
with a capacity for an inclination toward spirituality.
Here is Lisa Miller.
In terms of evaluating the sort of scientific based benefits
of cultivating a spiritual life
we should probably define what you mean by spirituality.
Great. So thank you.
So, as you are well aware,
scientists do not define spirituality all told,
but we can use the lens of science to identify threads
of lived human spiritual life
that have enormous impact on the rest of our lives,
our health, our wellness, our performance,
our ability to connect and love.
And the two threads within lived human spirituality,
where I focus in the awakened brain are the two areas
where the line share of science says,
our lives are entirely different.
These two threads of lived spirituality
are entirely game changing when it comes to our possibility
and our realization.
And they are one, the seat of transcendent awareness,
which is to say our innate, hardwired capacity
to see into the deeper nature of life
where we see that we are loved, held,
guided, and never alone.
There's a capacity hardwired on us
to see a transcendent relationship with life.
Mm-hmm.
That is the first of the two.
And the second is that,
that might be shared with one another,
so that we can show up and be part of that symphony of life
where we're loved, guided, held, and never alone
'cause we treat each other that way.
So religion is through the lens of science,
has been shown to be transmitted entirely environmentally.
It is a gift of our ancestors,
it is shared by community,
but spirituality, as I'm discussing it
in the awakened brain are innate capacity
for transcendent awareness
and that that might be shared, that is hardwired,
it is not merely a gift of our environment.
So spirituality is innate
and the environment alone transmits religion.
Sure. Innate and also heritable,
which is something we get into-
Yes.
which is super interesting.
But before we even do that,
I suspect that, and you talk about this in the book,
that it is a challenge for many
and obviously some within your profession
to kind of reconcile science and spirituality,
it presents this conundrum, this conflict,
spirituality being something
that is considered outside of science
that is something anecdotal and observational.
So walk me through the process of trying to drill down
on how you actually study,
not just the impact of a spiritual life
on one's mental health,
but just identifying it in a situation
where it can be calibrated to produce results
that are reliable and compelling enough
to draw conclusions from.
Okay, so Rich, many people will say,
indeed, I am not spiritual, I am very scientific.
And very often, certainly there was a huge ice age
around spirituality in the scientific community
in the 20th century, it's starting to thaw a bit now.
But for most of the 20th century and still many people,
the bad gift that science as a profession
gave our larger society was a false split
between spirituality and science,
and that is indeed a very false split.
It turns out that science is a method, it's a lens,
whether you're talking about genotyping or MRI studies
or long term clinical course studies,
science is a form of observance.
And we can point that lens at just about any question.
And the host of questions are broad.
We can ask questions
that are compelling and new
or we can repeat the same questions
we've asked a hundred times before.
The questions we ask live within the imagination
of the scientist.
So the limitations that science faced on turning our lens
to ask questions of spirituality in the human life
were limitations of the culture, the climate, the vogue
in which scientists were immersed,
they were not limitations of the scientific method.
Now, with the shift in culture
came a shift, really the thaw in the ice age
of the imagination of the scientist.
And as culture, really in some ways academia
was the last to the party,
our culture became much more spiritually aware
before academia got on board.
And as the group of scientists
who were early in this transformative process,
being amongst those labs that really brought
the lens of science to spirituality in the human life,
still to this day, I can say there's a number of scientists
who've yet to separate the difference between
the scientific method and the vogue, tastes and appetites
and the culture around academic science,
which are actually sort of implicitly,
latently secular material.
There's no reason that the scientific lens
has to be limited to interpretations or understandings
that are simply, I don't mean materialistic,
although that can come with material,
but material only that which we can touch,
which we can point to.
I literally have friends who are scientists
who say that because you've shown the neural correlates
of spirituality in the brain,
we now know spirituality's real.
Mm-hmm.
That is a limitation in the culture of scientists,
not in our method.
Then let's look just squarely at the science.
And the science says, we are all innately spiritual beings
with or without the embrace of religion.
We are all born with the spiritual core.
And if we build the spiritual core,
we have physical fitness for the physical core,
we need spiritual fitness for the spiritual core.
And if we do, we are 80% less likely to be addicted,
60% less likely to take our lives.
We're able to be whole and thrive.
We have disintegrated the spiritual core
from the rest of the person, and disintegration is unhealth.
So how do we put the spiritual core back in?
Well, if it's a public school or the public square,
it's minus religion that can happen at home.
But spirituality exists independent of religion
and how can we do that?
Again, at home the religious embrace of spiritual awareness
is important for many families,
roll with it, do that at home.
But in a public school,
we can strengthen the muscle of transcendent awareness,
of spiritual values towards one another.
And in fact, when we look in the MRIs
at the neuro correlates of the awakened brain
of all forms of spiritual practice,
that which most correlates with a strong spiritual awareness
is love of neighbor.
Love of neighbor and service altruism,
and that can be taught in school.
We have to do this work of formation,
we have no choice but to go on a spiritual quest.
Every tradition has known it.
When we foreclose the quest,
what we get is the big donut size hole in the heart,
we get the lack of formation,
the lack of the knowing heart, the perceiving heart,
that is a direct connection to God or the higher power.
The perceptual organ through which we say,
ah, he left me, she left me, but look who just showed up.
This ability to see that life is dynamic
and full of surprises and we don't make those surprises
and we don't make that dynamism,
but we can embrace this give and take,
this dialogue with life, that is quest.
The knowing of the heart is real, that's heart data.
So honoring and respecting the hunch,
the little whisper,
and the tiny, tiny little sapling of a hunch, honor that,
give it love, give it attention.
When you pay attention to your flashes of awareness,
when you catch a synchronicity out of the corner of your eye
and say, I think I saw something, honor that,
treat your perception as real.
And when you do it grows very, very quickly,
tenfold, a hundredfold.
Listen to yourself
and honor your inner knowing as heart data.
The spiritual path is described by some as a search for,
or an embodiment of a feeling of unconditional love.
But this next speaker, Professor Arthur Brooks,
takes it a step further
to claim that love is a decision, not a feeling.
Arthur is a professor at the Harvard Business School
and the bestselling author of
"From Strength to Strength,
A roadmap for Finding Success, Happiness,
and Deep Purpose In Our Later Years."
Here's a clip from our conversation.
I love all religions,
but I'm in love with the Catholic church.
And I learn as much about who I am as a Catholic by talking
to people who are not.
Yeah.
It's really, really important to talk to people
who are not you-
It's interesting.
because there's too much uniformity
and spiritual incompatibility
does not expose you to enough complementary.
Complementary in life is actually how you learn things.
You learn things from people who are different than you
in a lot of ways.
And who can
stress test your-
Stress test,
and also just they give you the better technique.
I mean, that studying with the Tibetan Buddhist monks
and Dalai Lama is how I learned to pray my rosary.
Wow.
Yeah, I learned how to pray the rosary
with my breath and heart
by studying with the Tibetan Buddhist monks.
Yeah, that's interesting.
Yeah.
And how many times have you visited with the Dalai Lama?
10, 11, something like that.
Wow.
Problem is that he's completely sequestered still,
he's 86-
Right.
or 87 now in July, it would be 87 in July.
But he's been in the states many times with me too.
So when he would come here,
we've been in different parts of the states
and I would interview him.
But we've written together too, which is-
And what would you say is the primary thing
that you've kind of extracted
from being in his presence?
The understanding that the decision
that love is the decision and not a feeling.
Elaborate.
It's that, well, Saint Thomas Aquinas said that,
"To love is to will the good of the other."
It's nothing about feelings,
and this is an ancient medieval teaching
that actually comes from Aristotle,
that love philia is a positive decision
on the basis of who we are as people.
And the Dalai Lama lives that every single day.
He says, you must decide to love, you must decide to love,
might not like.
To like as Martin Luther King said,
"To like someone is a sentimental something,
but to love somebody's a positive decision."
It's hard, it takes work,
it's a measure of who you are,
as a person is your decision to love
in a world full of hate.
And the Dalai Lama is living embodiment of that.
He's as wonderful as he seems.
I suspect that's true.
Yeah.
And it's interesting to hear love contextualized
as this action verb that you have control over.
Yeah.
It gives you
a sense of agency.
Absolutely.
And I think our western notion of it is backwards
in the sense that we're looking to receive love,
but we're not really adequately focused
on how we're giving it or we're exuding it.
Absolutely.
We're a feeling based society
and this is actually one of our great-
I mean, so one of your sort of preternatural gifts
is how you've engineered your life
on the basis of what you wanted it to be,
this is one of the reasons that I listen to your show
and many people do is because they want urgency.
They want to be fully alive and to be managed by themselves
as opposed to be managed by their urges, their impulses,
their appetites and their feelings,
that's a phenomenon that we call metacognition.
And you're the walking example of metacognition.
You made decisions on how you're going to live
and you live that way.
And that is not just a western brainy idea,
on the contrary, you know the Dalai Lama shows that,
and by understanding ourselves at a certain remove,
we can make these decisions for ourselves,
including how we're going to treat others,
the love that we're gonna show to the rest of the world.
You find that people tend to walk away from faith
or spirituality in their 20s
and the reason is 'cause the world's messy,
and you say, how can there be a benevolent creator
with so much pain in the world, etc.
And I understand that this is troubling to a lot of people.
But when you're our age, you're like,
yeah, everything's messy, nothing's consistent.
I can accept a whole lot of cognitive dissonance now
that I was unable to accept when I was 28 or 32 years old,
just couldn't do it.
And so the result of that is that
whereas superstitions tend to fall away,
I don't believe in the tooth fairy, the Easter Bunny,
I'm more willing to be childlike
in understandings of the supernatural.
Now for some people it doesn't work that way.
But here's the deal when it comes to happiness,
if you're left to your devices,
your ordinary quotidian devices,
your life is gonna be like a continuous tape loop
of one episode of "Better Call Saul."
Like it was okay the first time,
and then it's the same and the same,
and you'll go mad with tedium, with boredom.
It's just, really my job, my car, my money, my friends,
my time, my show, my me, me, me,
just gimme a break.
The Dalai Lama always says, every time I see him,
he says, "Remember, you are one in 7 billion."
By which he does not mean that I'm an ant,
that I'm insignificant,
by which he means don't forget the adventure
of looking at things from a distance.
Don't forget the adventure of seeing life in its spectrum,
it's majesty, it's scale.
At 40,000 feet, looking at the whole world
where you're part of it gives you perspective
and it gives you peace, you need that.
Everybody has a transcendental walk.
Now, maybe it comes from the incredible,
I mean, it's like, I hang out with a guy named Ryan Holiday.
Yeah, I just talked to him like two hours ago.
I talk to Ryan all the time.
He's fantastic-
We're close.
He's fantastic.
And he's cut his teeth by
introducing Marcus Aurelius
to a generation of Gen Z is like,
wow, Ryan Holiday discovered Seneca, it's awesome.
But he's so smart and so good.
He's such a-
Ryan's a visionary guy.
And you can study the philosophers or as I mentioned before,
the works of Bach or understanding nature
in a very metaphysical way,
or a traditional or non-traditional faith
or spiritual practice or a meditation practice.
There's lots of ways to do this,
but we must have a transcendental walk
because life is simply too intense and exhausting
and boring if we don't do that.
So how does one embark upon that
if this is a new alien concept?
Yeah, I've asked the Dalai Lama that very thing.
It's like asking for a friend kind of,
and I have my more traditional religious life
actually proceeds from this because I realized,
I mean there are times when I was more religious
and times when I was less religious,
but in my 30s I recognized
that this was a big hold in my soul
and I didn't need to go across state lines
to go to a different supermarket.
What precipitated that?
A need, I recognized a need
that I needed better, more peace and better perspective.
And I just have a sense that this is right.
Now, what part is right, I don't know.
I don't actually know, but I need a physics of spirituality.
And just as I would not try to create
my own mathematical structures,
to create my own alternative system of mathematics,
I don't feel like I have to do so in a religious way.
Other people feel differently about it.
But the Dalai Lama talks about kind of a pyramid,
where the basis of the pyramid is moral living figure.
And this is a yemen perspective too.
Carl Jung said that, "hHappiness comes from defining
your values and living according to them."
If you know what your values are
and you don't live according to them,
or you don't know what your values are, you won't be happy.
Defining your values and your morals
and living according to them with impeccable integrity,
that means when they say make your bed,
I mean that's a boring example
of living according to what you think is right.
And even when nobody's watching,
you're living according to it.
What I recommend is that, that people don't lie ever.
Just don't lie.
Now when the murderers at the door and says,
where's the victim? Fine.
But that's not what we're talking about.
That's a different podcast.
That's a Wondery podcast.
Or a Sam Harris podcast, maybe.
So figure out, write down what your moral values are
and make a plan to live according to them, step one.
Step two is build a meditative practice.
Build a practice of contemplation.
Maybe that's formal meditation,
maybe that's walking in the woods.
But you need a practice without devices
where you can be at peace.
And finally, you need to read wisdom.
You need to expose yourself to people
who've had deeper thoughts
and more profound thoughts than you.
So number one, act according to your values,
learn your values, act according to your values,
practice your values, write it down, journal it.
Number two, is get your contemplate to practice in order
and make sure you start with at least 15 minutes a day.
And number three, is actually read the wisdom literature
in whatever tradition you you want
and do that daily for at least 15 minutes.
Starting there, your life will change, it will,
your world will rock.
In this next clip, I sit down with my wife Julie,
also known SriMati as she takes us through
the power of the breath and the posture of yoga
as tools of activation for spiritual connection.
She explains how our regular practice
can result in a better life for ourselves.
One that breaks the bonds of our past habits
and allows us to reclaim our sovereignty.
Enjoy.
Intellectual conversation is wonderful.
It's amazing and it really is important for us as humans
to bond and connect and be inspired.
And then there is a whole other universe of transcendence
that happens in the processes of technique.
And you cannot transcend by talking about it.
It will only lead you to a certain place.
And we see this demonstrated in our sessions
of holotropic breathing when we're on retreat
and you see humans go into a breathing space
and there are people who have almost
never practiced yoga before
and they have transcending experiences.
You have witnessed it yourself.
Yeah, there are literally psychedelic experiences
that we were having.
Literally.
And again, it's like I worked with somebody today
who came to me who said,
I feel like my life has almost passed me by
and I have failed to access the spiritual part of who I am.
And just in one session she has such an awareness
of her spiritual nature.
Given the space, humans are connected to their spirituality,
we are truly, I heard you say it recently,
I'm a spiritual being having a human experience.
Right.
So water tiger
is this technique, is this portal of techniques
which are designed to lead you
into a deep relationship with your own being
because your life is about you and you alone.
It's not about my life,
and it's not about any of the kids' life,
it's about you and you alone.
And you have, we all have the opportunity
to choose our sovereign connection to our spiritual nature.
And what would those techniques be?
Oh, they're massive.
I mean, well, there's like 40
maybe in the portal right now.
There are devotional prayers,
there are techniques that lead you
to drop into the black fullness,
it's empty full space, it's not empty space.
But it's the void where you can replenish
in that meditative state and gather energy in that state.
And others are for amplifying presence,
amplifying your presence in your body.
There's a saying that, if you don't embody your life print,
meaning your physical body and your energetic bodies,
something or someone else will.
So meaning you could have an ancestral pattern
that is living inside of your life print
because you have not embodied that.
You have not claimed your energy back.
Right, so to put a finer point on that,
an example would be,
in my own case, me perpetuating a pattern
that was imprinted on me by my mother or my father
or the way that I was raised,
such that I'm not conscious that I'm in furtherance
of this unhealthy behavior pattern
and not totally aware of the fact that
it isn't actually me, it's the result of neural pathways
that got cemented when I was a very young person,
and thus feel reflexive as opposed to consciously chosen.
Yeah, it's an automatic pattern, we call it a miasm,
that is basically running in you.
So it means your sovereignty is not activated.
And then you end up doing the exact same behavior that you -
Promise you wouldn't.
Hated,
literally hated as a child-
Yeah.
to your child.
And this is not a, I mean this is everyone.
This is what we do and then you're like,
Oh my God, I'm acting like my mother.
Oh my god.
Right.
So the point is, is that,
I always say of anything that transformed my life
in a positive way, in a transcendent way
it was the practice of yoga, physical asanas,
which you and I met in that environment.
Mm-hmm.
And yoga techniques are a shelter from the storms.
No matter what's happening,
if the world is ending, practice yoga.
It's like, it creates an awareness
of energy that is beyond space and time.
It empowers your energetic,
it expands your ability to live free.
And I'm not saying go into a yogic sect
and get into all the lineage and all the teachings.
I'm just saying just get on the mat,
develop a meditation practice,
and ask ourselves, like those of us who have apps
who say they meditate and are running around.
I mean really, like how much are you really meditating?
Are you really meditating or are you listening to a podcast?
Are you reading more news?
If you just took your life like a pie
and look at your energetic,
the the amount of energy that's available,
how much of the time are you engaged
in intellectual activities,
pontificating, analyzing, judging, assessing, summing up,
like on a daily basis in this coliseum of life
that we find ourselves in now?
And how much time have you been in nature?
Have you stopped?
Are you connecting with your breath?
And I mean, being in nature, not listening to a podcast,
not listening to music,
dropping in, sitting with a tree, like dropping in.
Like are we communicating on that level?
Hm-mmm.
So what I can do as an individual
is I can dedicate my meditation
to expanding the power in my energetic field.
And this could be through breath, through presence,
through dropping into the state, the void.
And what I'm doing is I'm amplifying
the amount of light that I'm able to hold.
And then I bring into my heart this feeling of peace,
of humanity, of love,
of where every human has a safe place to live,
food to eat, place to love their children.
And I amplify that as much as I can.
And then I say to the one breath.
hear my prayer,
may all my brothers and sisters who are suffering
feel my presence that I am with them
and that I hold this vision
for a more expanded life experience together.
And that could seem trite,
and silly and ridiculous to an intellectual,
but thoughts are things, energy is something.
I feel like humans are not hardwired
to inhabit that disposition.
And that's why it is a practice,
and things like meditation and yoga
are so crucial for developing that internal connectivity
because humans in our minds
are disposed to pattern recognition,
we're looking for patterns.
Like, oh, these things are always like this
and so that's the way this is.
And we observe things and we listen and we hear
and we assemble experiences
and we try to extract greater truths out of them,
and the practice is about detaching from that
and understanding that that's just a very small piece
of the story of reality,
which is another way of saying -
It might not be reality at all, actually.
Yeah.
Quite, quite honestly.
Right.
In either camp-
Mm-hmm.
Any ideas that I have about meditation,
it's probably not that.
So I'm just saying like it would benefit us
to develop some reverence for the great one breath,
the ancient force that is inhabiting all life
and to return to some of the ways of the indigenous,
of listening to the winds and the trees and the earth,
and the air and the fires.
And so, listen, we have a lot of things
that are inciting fear in the world
and there's a lot of systems that we believed in
or maybe we're an illusion over
that we have put our our trust in, I guess.
And what I would say is the only thing you have,
the only thing you have is your connection to consciousness
through your own heart, that's it.
Everything else will fall away,
this relationship will fall away,
the kids will go their own way,
people come into your lives, they go,
careers come in, they go.
But what do you have?
You have your consciousness.
And if you're still here,
if you're listening to this podcast,
if you have a dream,
if you have a desire,
if you have breath in your body,
really, really embody that.
It's a precious gift to be here.
And we all agreed to come here
to be part of this transformation.
And transformation is happening,
but it's our job to hold the highest vision.
And it's not about political parties or us and them,
or masculine versus feminine,
it's about integration and the community.
This next clip is from one of my favorite people,
comedian Pete Holmes.
Pete grew up in a fundamentalist Christian environment
and actually studied to become a youth pastor
before pivoting to standup comedy.
In this clip, Pete explains
what initially drew him to faith.
He then unpacks his current spiritual perspective
and shares the practices that have helped him
become a more fulfilled version of himself.
The mantra that I think you adopt
and you point this out in the book,
is this idea of what is this,
Yeah.
what is going on,
like this sense at a very young age
where you're walking around
and everyone's living their lives
and you have this undeniable sensibility of awe
and wonder about the world
and what is actually happening on this crazy,
spinning blue thing-
Yeah.
we're out in space and the sky is up
but it's also sideways-
And it's also below you.
Exactly.
All of that.
The sky is below you.
And just confused
why no one wants to talk about that.
Yeah.
And that ultimately seems to be,
in addition to your mother's impetus,
like what leads you into the church
and where you find a home for
debating and talking about these things
that also then informs your comedy.
"The What Is This" was my thing as a kid
and it manifested in being very interested in UFOs
and Bigfoot and ESB and all these different things-
This made you immediately popular.
Very popular.
And comedy, comedy is also like-
Comedy is like playing operation,
we're trying to figure out
where the boundaries of socialness lie.
And then that "What Is This"
kind of got funneled into the church.
And what I liked about the church was
we didn't really debate as much,
but at least they said, God, which I liked.
I enjoyed that they had an answer that was different from,
well, I don't know, eat your fucken tacos,
who cares, we gotta get to school.
It was nice that they were saying God,
because God was something.
I make a comparison in the book
where I was leaving a superhero movie
and I heard a kid say to his dad,
Dad, how do they make that man fly?
And the dad without really thinking about it,
just went computers.
And I was like, that's very funny
'cause computers really just means I don't know.
He's just saying, I don't know.
And in the same way God might mean I don't know,
but at least it was something,
at least it gave us a symbol
and something to explore and unpack
if you're feeling curious.
Computers or God, it gave me a foothold.
But then I lose my faith because my wife leaves me.
And I felt like I had been paying protection money to God.
I think a lot of people feel this way, like the mafia.
And yet still someone had thrown for the fifth time
a brick through my bakery window.
I'm like, what am I paying this guy for?
You know what I mean?
I'm his sheep,
Right.
Shepherded me.
Sheeps don't have their wife sheep get fucked by a wolf.
Like you fucked up, that's how I felt.
So he didn't hold up his end of the bargain
in my sort of third grade,
second grade kindergarten understanding of God.
But that was one of the things is when my wife left
I had to take a real hard look at like,
do you really believe that?
Like, the example I use in my book is,
my brother is going to hell, he didn't believe like I did,
do you really believe that?
Like really, really think about it.
And I was like, well, my behavior
is maybe more honest than my thoughts.
And my behavior was very clear,
I wasn't really actively grabbing him going,
you fool, there's a train coming,
Right.
And you're on the tracks,
you idiot.
I wasn't doing that. I was having tacos with him,
tacos again.
So then I lose it and then I'm out in the wild
and I start kind of feeling growing up a little bit
and all these kind of interesting things.
And then I took mushrooms with my girlfriend at Bonnaroo
and we just thought it was like something fun to do.
I wasn't a big drug person, I'm not a big drug person,
I hadn't done a lot of drugs,
I'd probably smoked pot like, I don't know,
15 times in my life at that point.
And then we bought some mushrooms from a roadie
and we went on the Ferris wheel.
And at the time, I would not have said
that I experienced the divine.
What I did experience was something
that was completely beyond language.
So what we're saying, it was trans rational,
it didn't make any sense.
It wasn't something I thought,
it was something that I became,
and this sounds like if you read other people writing
about mystical experiences, that's what they say.
You can think I am made of the same molecules
as this table and as you
and yet here are two consciousnesses talking to each other,
it's fucken trippy.
But to become that, that'll lay you on your back.
And it did.
And I laid there, now with the gait,
staring at the clouds and receiving like direct, real,
even after I'd come down,
real transmission from the universe grabbing me and saying,
we're so glad you're finally fucken here.
So you can put down your briefcases
filled with your precious little beliefs.
And you're in, I'm in.
I'm a Christian, I'm in.
Get all that shit outta here,
lay the fuck down on some grass
and stare up towards infinity, you idiot,
which is always there, you idiot
and really like, listen to me for a second.
Stop praying by thinking, God help me find parking.
God help me beat that flu that's going around and listen,
shut up for a second.
So turn your brain off for a second.
And that just plays directly into your main thing,
which is what is this.
Exactly.
And I was finally getting a taste
and it was through something.
It wasn't from, as Richard Rohr would say,
it wasn't from doing it right, abstaining from drugs,
it was from doing it wrong.
What a beautiful paradox.
God hides himself in pain
and strange wayward afternoons in Tennessee.
That's fucken gorgeous.
That's amazing.
So I did mushrooms and then I realized
there were some things that we can't really talk about.
And then I started, my heart,
I didn't know had opened up to the potential
that the writers of things like the Bible
were also trying to use myth and metaphor.
Because as Richard Rohr says,
"Metaphor is the only language we have to talk about God."
That doesn't mean it's not true,
it means it's so big and vast and mysterious
that how else are you gonna talk about it?
I'm sorry to be so aggressive.
But like, you're gonna talk about it directly.
You're gonna talk about it
like the contents of your refrigerator?
You're gonna add it to your Amazon wishlist,
the mystery of everything?
You can't talk about it directly.
You can talk about it through music, sex, drugs,
poetry and metaphor.
So once I opened up the idea that Jesus's death
and resurrection, for example, is a metaphor for your death,
your ego death and your resurrecting
to the dynamic source of all being.
So you need to wake up to Christ consciousness, basically.
Suddenly, it wasn't about worshiping someone else's story.
I write about it in the book, like, Jesus was-
You're on a football team with Jesus
and He does this incredible return after a pun or whatever,
I don't know, football.
Yeah.
So He catches the ball and he runs it back
to like His own 30 yard line,
but then He gets tackled
and the ball splits out and falls in your arms.
And instead of like running with the ball,
you put the ball down so you can-
(Pete applauding)
Wow.
Applaud Jesus.
That was amazing Jesus.
And Jesus is going, you idiot, go,
this story isn't about me, it's about you.
And worshiping someone else's story
isn't gonna do shit for you.
Like we need you to do it.
You die, you die.
You know what I'm saying, I get all passionate about this.
No, I like that so-
It's one thing, like I believe this, so I'm in a club
is way different from going, oh, I saw what he did,
I'll do it too.
I can't literally raise from the dead
and I can't literally heal the blind,
and I can't literally turn water into wine,
but I can metaphorically.
And I have and I do and you do too.
Yeah.
And that's what
we're supposed to be doing.
So if somebody was to say to you,
Pete, how do you define your faith?
How do you canonize it?
How do you articulate your perspective on these things?
I'm a Christ-leaning spiritual seeker person.
(Pete laughs)
I still enjoy that because for better or worse,
those things got in there and were imprinted on me
when I was young.
So I get very excited when I can reclaim those stories
and bring them with me
and not throw the baby out with the bath.
But a lot of it, I spent so much of my life thinking,
how to be more like Jesus,
would wear those bracelets to say, WWJD
what would Jesus do?
We wanted to be like Jesus as if Jesus-
Like the point of Jesus was how nice He was
and how He got along with everybody.
And when people say, how can I be more like Christ?
I'm like, when?
Like in between each of those words,
I think you're probably closer than you think.
And we when we can stop and turn the volume down.
This is very unpleasing to the ego,
when we think it's not about having something,
it's about letting go of something, but stillness and quiet,
be still and know that I'm God,
that it's right there staring you in the face.
It's about getting into your pure basic awareness.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition.
The thing is, most people I know actually
already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is the Plantpower meal planner.
Our affordable, all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit MEALS.RICHROLLS.COM.
And right now for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code, RRHEALTH, at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people
for just a $1,70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's MEALS.RICHROLL.COM,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
One of the more challenging aspects of spiritual practice
is the act of forgiveness.
Here to offer wise counsel on this subject
is spiritual thought leader,
activist and former presidential candidate,
Marianne Williamson.
How can we extend forgiveness to others and to ourselves?
And how does that spiritual practice
affect the way we interact with others
in our lives and on social media?
Here's Marianne.
How do we develop the facility to forgive,
and why is that so important in terms of living our lives
in a manner in which to be most whole and complete?
Well, I'm a student of a Course In Miracles
and the concept of forgiveness,
which is central to a Course In Miracles,
presents the word in a very different way
than it is presented within
traditional Christian terminology
or any religious terminology.
Usually when we think of forgiveness,
it's, you're a jerk,
but I'm so spiritual now that I dare to forgive you.
The condescending.
My favorite kind of forgiveness.
It's judgment to destroy the Course In Miracle says.
But forgiveness within a deeply spiritual
metaphysical concept means knowing
that we are all created by God as innocent and good,
and we make mistakes.
And how you treat
and that God does not punish us for our sins.
Sin is an archery term, means you missed the mark.
He seeks to correct us for our mistakes.
And when you are in that place,
you realize that the love,
that is who you are and who I am is real,
the rest is this mortal hallucination that we're having.
Buddha called an an illusion.
Einstein said, "Time and space are illusions
of consciousness, albeit persistent ones."
That there was some bedrock of love, an alterable love,
that is the truth of who we are.
And I think that everything that we're talking about today,
if you stand on that, that our function on this earth
is to see that love in each other
and to stand on that love, and to invoke that love.
Everything changes.
Your criminal justice system changes,
your economic system changes,
your personal relationship changes,
your treatment of the earth changes.
Now, that doesn't mean you don't say no,
sometimes love says no.
Forgiveness doesn't make you a doormat,
forgiveness simply makes you someone
who's capable of owning your yes and owning or no.
You have children.
If a child, a small child walks into the kitchen,
Hi mommy and daddy, look at this razor blade I found.
You know it is incumbent upon you out of love
for that child to make sure the razor blade
is taken out of their hands.
But you don't look at that child and forget who they are
just because they were so uninformed
and not old enough to realize
you can't play with razor blades.
Forgiveness means knowing that who we are is good.
Living on this earth we forget that.
But when I look at you and I base my perception of you
only on your error, only on your lovelessness,
then I am stuck within that realm of lovelessness.
And the course of miracle says,
"You are at the effect of the laws
that prevail within the world that you identify with."
If I'm willing to extend my perception
beyond what my physical senses perceive,
your error, your lovelessness,
to what I know to be true in you,
then I remind both you and myself what is true in us
and the situation repairs.
Hmm.
And we're gonna have to do that on a larger level,
the hatred, the cynicism,
the anger on both the left and the right,
dispels and deflects the possibility for political miracles.
And we must open our hearts
and still passionately disagree,
form boundaries, just like you have boundaries
in personal relationships,
you have boundaries in political relationships.
But you can do all of that with love.
You can do all of that with respect and humility.
And to me that's the portal.
Yeah.
To which we can walk to a more sustainable world.
The resistance to forgive that impulse that we feel
when we we sense that we've been wronged
is ostensibly to shoulder a burden.
It's a self punishment,
and there is a liberation or a freedom that happens
when you can develop the facility to let go of it,
to forgive as difficult as that might be.
It is.
And that forgiveness
should be, sort of turned inward as well,
like self forgiveness is-
Well, you can't forgive yourself
if you don't forgive others,
that's why the course says,
"You become generous out of self-interest."
The course says, when you're attacking someone,
blaming someone,
imagining that there is a sword falling down on their head,
but it's actually falling down on yours
because at the deepest level,
if you get into the metaphysic of it,
there's no place where you stop and I start.
Yeah.
None of us,
except enlightened masters are perfect at any of this.
But even making the effort transforms our lives.
Yeah, we've all seen our soul elevated
by witnessing somebody forgive somebody
where logic would dictate that maybe they shouldn't.
And we understand fundamentally that that is a noble act,
that that is nourishing.
And yet we're in a culture
where we're increasingly judging everybody
based on their worst day and canceling people,
and saying, you go away now and that's it for you.
There is no room, at least in the social media space,
for that forgiveness.
Unless we find a way back to that,
a way to prioritize it
and inject it into our kind of discourse and conduct,
we're lost.
You are so right.
I think you put it so well,
we're judging everybody according to their worst day
or their most stupid tweet.
Everything is, I gotcha.
It's terrible.
Many years ago, my best friend who has since passed,
we were sitting in my bedroom and I was on the phone
with someone who worked for me
and I started yelling at the guy.
I got off the phone and Richard said to me, "What was that?"
And I said, Well, he did this or he didn't do that,
or whatever it was.
And Richard looked at me and he went,
"Marianne, he made a mistake.
People make mistakes."
It was a brick to my forehead, I remember.
And no matter what he did,
the fact that you were such a bitch about it
makes you no better than-
I got it.
I mean, I'm not a hundred percent practicing it,
but a lot better than I used to be
because people make mistakes.
Yeah, so how do we try to create space for that?
The Course Of Miracle says, you say,
Dear God, I'm willing to see this differently.
The path that we are here to monitor is not somebody else's.
It's like you were talking about,
hey, hey, you're not here
to take somebody else's inventory.
Right.
You the path,
you're here to monitor very vigilantly as your own.
Dear God, I see how self-righteous I am in this moment.
Dear God, I see how judgmental I am in this moment.
Dear God, I see how blaming,
like how do I think I am.
Dear God, take this away from me.
And then, and I see this all the time,
then what happens is sometimes you realize,
just keep your mouth shut,
there's nothing that even needs to be said.
Sometimes you realize, oh, there's something
that's gonna need to be communicated here,
but you will communicate it from such a different place.
You will communicate it from elegance,
and charity and compassion.
The Course Of Miracle says,
"If you're judging and attacking someone,
you're wrong even if you're right."
Right, but we have a social media ecosystem.
Oh yeah, we do.
That has a misalignment of incentives
because it's rewarding people
for that level of judgment and invective.
We do, but each and every one of us
can refuse to participate in that and do what we can,
because there's also some beautiful stuff on social media.
You know there's a line in the course where it says,
"Nothing in the world is unholy or holy
except as determined by its purpose,
what the mind is doing with it."
And you can see incredible things,
credible good that comes from social media,
and you can see terrible even evil things
that emerge from social media.
It all gets back to the ethics
and the principles of right and wrong
and enlightenment that I do think so many of us
are at least trying for.
A New York Times bestselling author, monk, philanthropist,
activist and teacher, his holiness, Radhanath Swami
is a man that radiates love,
he radiates compassion and grace
with this really sweet and joyous disposition
that has immeasurably impacted millions of souls
across the world.
In this next clip, Radhanath explains the idea
of a spiritual calling
and how following a calling can shape someone
into the person they were meant to become.
We all have our calling
and it's not really so important what age
we have that calling.
But when that calling for goodness,
when that calling for truth,
when that calling for light,
when that calling to be the change
that you want to see in the world.
And I deeply believe it's God's calling
coming from within us
which could echo from around us through other voices too.
But ultimately it's a calling from within.
We all have our ways of responding to that calling too,
but in my life this is how I responded to that calling.
Hmm.
Yeah, I suppose in order to heed
whatever calling is happening,
you have to be present and aware enough
to notice it's a rising.
And sometimes situations in the world that are startling,
that are worrisome,
even sometimes situations that appear hopeless,
they alert us to responding to that calling.
So you find yourself in London,
you're trekking about Europe,
you're in Athens,
you're sitting on the banks of the Thames
in London at night,
soaking in the moon, watching the river flow.
At some point you have this undeniable urge
or calling to go to India.
So walk me through that experience.
Well, coming from northern Illinois,
I went to Europe with two of my friends.
We were supposed to be there for just two months
and then come back for going back to college.
I went to one semester of a college
(Radhanath Swami laughing)
and that was the plan, that was our plan.
But we got robbed the first day we were in Europe
and we had no money,
and one of my friends went back to America that same day
and the other-
We made the scene in various places
and we were very popular,
and in many ways we saw there was the world
was opening up to us like anything,
even though we really didn't have a home,
or money or anything
just because the interactions
with such beautiful people and such opportunities.
But this calling, this little whisper
to find a spiritual connection
was always there in my heart,
and it was getting louder and louder and louder,
and that's really what started me on this quest.
I was spending a lot of time on riverbanks and in forests
and I was meditating and reading
various spiritual literatures from various religions.
I was going to synagogues,
I was going to churches, I was going to cathedrals.
I lived in Catholic monasteries.
I was studying, I was searching,
I was going to museums to study art,
to find spiritual clues.
And eventually I was living in a cave
on the Island of Crete, which is part of Greece.
And I was just praying to God for direction.
And it was there that I had this voice within my heart
that said, go to India.
And I had never met an Indian person in my life,
I've never ate a chili pepper in my life.
I had no map, I had no money for a map,
but I just left my friend the next day
and started hitch hiking to India.
(Radhanath Swami and Rich laughing)
And I just believed if I just go in the eastern direction,
eventually I'll get there.
You're gonna get there eventually.
You travel through Afghanistan,
you're immersed in extreme poverty in that situation,
you're in Pakistan,
you have this extraordinary story about getting caught up
at the border between Pakistan and India.
Can you tell that story?
Well, I hitchhiked through Turkey
and then Iran,
and then through Afghanistan and Pakistan.
The whole trip took over four months.
Now I get on an airplane from London
and I do it in nine hours, the same amount of distance,
but it's not as educational.
(Radhanath Swami laughs)
But it's much safer for sure.
Finally, when I was in the European countries,
I was studying Christianity and Judaism.
When I was in the Middle East,
I was studying Islam from some Islamic scholars
and very holy people actually.
And when I finally came to the border of India.
India and Pakistan have been in conflict politically
since the partition.
And there's a no man's land between the two countries.
And when I left the border of Pakistan,
I had to walk a couple hours through this no man's land
to get to India.
And at that time the, the border post was in a forest
near the city of Firozpur in Punjab.
And when I arrived
they asked how much money I had.
And as far as I remember, I had 26 cents
in about four different currencies.
(Rich laughs)
And the immigration agent was very, very angry.
She said that, "We have enough beggars in India,
we don't want another one.
Go back to where you came from."
Mm-hmm.
And I pleaded with her
that I just hitchhiked from London
and I got so many diseases that almost killed me,
and people tried to kill me,
and so many difficulties I had to get here
because I want to learn from your people.
Please give me a chance.
And she wouldn't do it.
So for hours and hours and hours
I was just sitting under a tree
and kept coming back and asking and getting rejected.
But the problem was I couldn't go back to Pakistan either
'cause I only had a one time visa,
so I was in this no man's land
and there were no cell phones in 19-
This was 1970.
And there was no phone booths, there was no-
I was just there.
And finally, just around the sunset time,
the guards changed,
and one man from the Sikh community
who was a soldier took the post.
And after the other immigration drove off in a jeep,
I went to him and this man said to me
that I have been ordered by my commanding officer
to reject you unless you show me at least $200.
At that point, I cried and I really cried
because I was 19 years old and it was hopeless.
And I begged.
I said, I've given up everything of my life
to learn from your country and to learn for your people.
Please just give me a chance
and I promise you that someday
I'll do something good for the people of India.
And being an immigration agent,
he looked into my eyes with such a interrogating glance.
He was just looking into my mind and into my heart.
For about a minute, he just stared at me.
And then he spoke,
he said, "Sometimes a man must follow his heart
and even though I have been ordered to reject you,
I am going to give you the chance that you're crying for."
And then he stamped my passport and said,
"Welcome to India."
I love that, that's beautiful.
I feel like you need to reunite with him.
I would like to see you visit him again
and recount that story to him.
I wish we could.
Yeah.
But that was,
this year marks 50 years since that event happened.
Mm-hmm.
And so what was it about this experience in India
that was so compelling and transformative for you?
Well, I went to the Himalayas
and I was studying from Yogis,
some of them were living in the forest,
in mountains and in caves.
And I was going to different ashrams
of different saints or gurus.
Some of them were very famous,
some of them were unknown to the world.
I was studying Burmese Buddhism,
and Zen Buddhism and Tibetan Buddhism,
I met people who were from the Bahai faith,
I was really trying to understand.
And of course within the Hindu faith
there's so many different branches
of ways of approaching the one supreme being.
So I was just like a little sponge
that was absorbing and absorbing and absorbing and learning.
And many situations were such blessings to my heart.
Some of them were very disappointing,
and some of them were enthralling
and so full of joy and gratitude.
But they all kind of were bringing me forward in my search.
And Rich, I ended up like this.
We continue this exploration of faith
with one of the most fascinating spiritual leaders
in America today.
A Lutheran pastor and public theologian
dedicated to redefining how we think about church,
how we practice religion,
how we ritualize divinity and cultivate community.
I'm talking about Nadia Bolz-Weber.
In this clip, Nadia and I discussed the concept of grace,
how it's often inconvenient and frustrating
and how it can lead us towards living lives
filled with more compassion.
I mean, the thing I've written about
more than anything and spoken about
more than anything in my career is the idea of grace.
And grace is a really difficult thing for us
because it inherently means the ball's not in our court.
You can't earn it,
it's not something that you climb toward,
it's something that you get.
And on some level we think if it's free,
it must be worthless.
And so I think that people, instead of focusing on grace
like to focus on being good.
But being good has never set me free
in the way that truth has
and things that have interrupted me from outside of me.
Well, I think good or the pursuit of being good
is the thing that provokes the feelings of less than,
and shame and guilt-
Absolutely.
And insecurity.
Whereas grace is permissive.
Like grace is also something that you describe
as being a pain in the ass from time to time.
Totally.
Like it's inconvenient.
For sure, especially,
So explain.
When it's-
The reason grace is tricky
is because I wanna feel like
I've made myself worthy of something.
And if it's truly grace,
it means it has nothing to do with worthiness, it just is,
and that's hard.
And then also grace sucks
because if it's true for me,
it means it also is true for the people who've hurt me.
Right.
And I don't like that.
That's definitely inconvenient.
I don't like that.
Right.
And I'm all for it until we get to that.
That's why I always say that like with my luck,
I'll be seated at the heavenly banquet
between like Anne Colter and some racist cop.
Yeah, right, exactly, but that's you.
Like if you believe in grace,
it's like, it's super uncomfortable in that way
because self-righteousness is just never an option.
And I love self-righteousness like I love chocolate and so-
It's intoxicating.
It is.
But self righteous-
And purity plays right into that.
A hundred percent.
Because if you really
feel like you're more pure than your fellow person-
Yeah.
You're right
on your bully pulpit to be self-righteous.
Yeah, totally.
Yeah.
Well that's why it was that,
that moment was so interesting
when I was interviewing Lance Armstrong.
I had that conversation with Lance Armstrong
on stage on Nantucket
because that day it was so interesting
when people knew I was and so on.
I'm like obsessed with the idea of compassion right now,
but not like as a virtue to adopt to be good, fuck that,
nothing's ever worked like that for me.
Like, if someone's like, Oh, did you read
that really great book about compassion?
I'd be like, yeah, not interested.
But because I'm such a pragmatist,
I'm super interested in the effect of compassion,
that I'm interested in.
Because when somebody's been in a true space of compassion
right across from me,
it's moved the needle for me
in terms of considering something
I hadn't considered on my own,
seeing a way I might have been wrong.
Like it's a safe and it's a loose place
to consider those things.
Whereas when someone's been accusatory
or challenging or calling me out,
I immediately get defensive.
Of course.
I can't hear it.
So I'm just obsessed with this idea
of what's the effect of compassion on me
or even on my body in conversations.
And so this person I know who does trauma work,
they work with people in trauma,
I was asking them like,
how in the world do you manage
to not be completely depleted all the time,
taking in these stories?
Mm-hmm.
And she had this image I just can't get over,
which is she said, "I imagine the heart of God,
like right behind my heart,
so that whatever that person is saying,
I feel it genuinely 'cause it comes through my heart,
but it doesn't land there.
It lands in the heart of God.
And then anything that comes out of me towards them
doesn't originate from my own resources and deplete me,
it originates from the heart of God
and just comes through me.
Right, that's a good-
Obsessed with this.
Well that's a very unique and specific way
of imagining healthy boundaries for yourself.
Right, right.
Okay, so that day when people knew
I was the one having a conversation with Lance,
they said, Hey, don't let him off easy.
Like people would come up to me all day and be like-
Well, when it comes to Lance,
everyone's gonna have an opinion or some advice.
Right, okay.
But like why?
Right, so-
What is the end game?
Because we love to know who we're better than,
we're obsessed with it.
So if somebody's so obviously had a fall from grace,
there is this scapegoating instinct in the human being,
is almost inescapable.
This is why, like when Brian Williams,
when his career had that huge bump
because he didn't actually falsify a news account,
he exaggerated a personal story,
which by the way, we all have done.
And every single time we do it,
it creates an icky feeling in us.
And those icky feelings build up
and we have to do something with them.
So what do we do?
We wait until someone like Brian Williams comes along
and we just throw all of our icky shit
that we don't wanna tell anyone onto them,
and then we have to kill 'em.
It's this collective way of relieving the anxiety
and think-
And we think that's gonna
make us feel better.
That's right.
But actually it's like empty calories.
It completely is.
Yeah.
I mean, self-righteousness,
I always say feels good for a minute but only in a way
that peeing your pants feels warm for a minute.
Right.
Then you smell bad,
it's cold, you know what I mean.
Okay, so I'm having this conversation with Lance and I-
Can I just, hold on, let me just say one thing.
Yeah.
I don't wanna interrupt you, but like,
this was my first exposure to you
and everybody needs to know,
you're all right, so Nadia's gonna interview Lance
and it's in the round at this very cool event
called "The Nantucket Project."
And your opening line to him-
This is what I'm telling.
Yeah.
Okay, so I won't steal it.
No, no, no, okay, this is where I'm going.
So just so you know, they had asked me,
Nadia, would you-
So I'm really interested in compassion right now,
I'm only really experimenting with it,
I don't want anybody to be impressed.
It's like I'm just-
I'm dabbling in compassion.
Okay, but I'm thinking about it a lot.
And they said, "Would you have a conversation on stage
with Lance Armstrong?"
And I said, Yeah, I totally would.
Then they said, "Would you have a conversation on stage
with Sean Spicer?"
And I said, No, fuck that guy.
(Nadia laughs)
Like, just to say, my ability to be open and compassion.
Yeah.
Fucken limited, okay.
So, I get to that day, everyone's like,
give him a hard time, da-da, da-da.
And I sit there and I have that image of compassion,
of having God's heart behind mine
and sort of being open to this human being across from me
as a person with a unique story
and that most of which none of us know.
Most of us don't really know this human being's full story.
And I said to him, opening thing I said was,
Lance, I see from my notes that you took drugs
you weren't supposed to and then you lied about it.
And then I said, Oh my God, I did that shit so many times.
(Nadia laughs)
It was so great.
And everyone-
How long did it take you
to figure that line out?
It was just that day.
Really?
It was like, how's this gonna happen?
And so-
It just broke the ice.
Totally, and he laughed.
And everybody-
He laughed so hard.
There was like catharsis,
not just with him,
the whole audience.
The whole room.
His like holding-
And then I looked around-
this tension.
I dunno if you remember,
I said, you raise your hand audience,
if you at any point in your life took drugs
you weren't supposed to and lied about it.
And people were like, yeah, I did that shit
and they raised their hand.
Yeah, but-
But there's also a lot of,
yeah, but-
Correct, I get that, I get.
And it's tricky with Lance-
Yeah.
I see the gray and I've interviewed him for this podcast-
True.
And I got the same thing.
Like, you weren't hard enough, you were too hard.
I mean, everybody's got an opinion on this guy
and my only agenda was,
I want to understand this person better.
Yeah.
He's on the receiving end
of a lot of criticism
and a lot of celebratory pats on the back,
like how confusing for-
Totally.
a human being.
and how many people on planet earth have been
as high as he has gone.
Yes.
And as low.
That's right.
And that's inherently fascinating.
Completely.
And it's incredibly human
to explore that.
Yeah, yeah.
One of the biggest spiritual and existential questions
that humanity has grappled with for millennia
is what happens when we die?
And here to respond to that question
are Rainn Wilson & Reza Aslan
from the Metaphysical Milkshake podcast.
Each of them shares their perspective on the afterlife,
but more importantly reflects on the implications
for how what we believe about the afterlife
affects how we live while we're here.
Here's Rainn and Reza.
What happens after we die, I've talked about.
My belief as a Bahai, in a Bahai faith
we believe that there's an analogy that the body-
It's not just the Bahai faith,
there's many spiritual traditions that the body is a cage,
and that our reality is the bird within the cage.
And when the cage is broken, the bird goes free,
and that's not something to be mourned,
the brokenness of the body or of the cage,
it's to be celebrated,
the glorious journey of the bird flying free
of the material and physical limitations.
But I will say that, I recently had a friend pass away
and this has been a big year of death for me.
My father passed away about a year ago,
the co-founder of our nonprofit in Haiti died of cancer,
and then one of my dear friends died of cancer-
Sorry to hear that.
Thanks. Recently.
It's such a tricky topic,
but there are good ways to die
and there's not so good ways to die.
And in fact, one of our episode,
I'm sorry, I feel like I'm really plugging
the hell out of this podcast.
Well, we do ask a lot of these questions so you know-
But you're here to do that anyway.
A little bit.
Just wean into it brain.
We had a death doula on the show and she was amazing.
And that's like a birth doula.
She's exactly what you think it is, yeah.
And she helps you transition towards death.
And that can be everything from like,
where do you keep all your Facebook passwords?
And also, how do you want your ceremony to be?
How do you wanna pass?
What do you want
your death bed to look like?
Yeah,
that was the big question on your death bed.
So in having these discussions we talk a lot about death
and this friend of mine who passed away,
like he didn't wanna look at death.
And I think probably because he was mostly atheist,
I think that he was like a third, wondering but mostly-
And so for him, his journey towards
this inevitability of death
'cause he was given stage four stomach cancer,
was like, I'm gonna fight cancer,
tooth and nail with every power in my being.
Which is great.
Right.
Which is important.
But fueled by this terror.
Fueled by terror
and a kind of like-
I would be always the voice to talk to him and say,
David, can we talk about this a little bit?
Or I would send him like a little writing about
from the Dalai Lama or a Buddhist text
or something about death.
And I would encourage him to get some therapy,
help process the emotions around it.
But we live in the western culture,
in this abject terror of death.
We don't talk about death.
A friend of mine was telling me that
now in contemporary society,
like the Victorians never talked about sex,
but talked about death all the time in Victorian England.
The were death parties
and there would be corpse viewings and seances.
And there was just this thing.
And sex was like not talked.
Now we just talk about sex and everything is like,
reality TV shows are just literally like,
Hey, who these people are gonna hook up.
But this idea that we are so afraid to talk about death.
Yeah.
And it is the one thing
that we all have in common,
everyone on this podcast
and everyone listening to this podcast.
And if we embrace it as a continuation of the mystery,
and yes, it's scary,
we can have a very different relationship to death.
Yeah, yeah, I think it is less about
what happens when we die.
I mean, anybody who answers that question
with any level of certitude
is somebody I'm probably not going to trust.
I think you right.
(Rainn and Rich laugh)
I just couldn't say that.
But it is about appreciation of death
and how to bring death into our daily experience
so that we can appreciate the richness of life.
Because that is a certitude and a certain duality
that we need to understand.
Our culture is so whitewashed of any references
to death whatsoever.
And despite our brains, intellectually.
Look at the mass denial happening
in our country right now.
It's unbelievable.
650,000 people dead in our country
in a year and four months,
and we're not talking about it.
And they're partying like it's 1999
and there's no one is looking.
And so half of the population is going,
I'm sorry to say this,
is going like, what the fuck?
Yeah.
And I know that gets-
I think it is a reflection of this very thing,
because we're so afraid of death and we have so little,
I mean, like, we don't connect with it in any way.
Like the minute somebody dies,
they're removed from our line of sight.
And we don't have language
for how to talk about it in a healthy way
beyond kind of like the traditional structures
around funerals etc.
And I think intellectually we all understand
that we're gonna die,
but I think deep down,
we all think somehow we're gonna figure out
and run around it, for us personally.
Yeah.
And that creates that like low grade fear
that we carry with us,
that forces us to even put it further out our-
Well, I think the answer is ultra-marathons.
Yeah.
Here's what I would say, yeah, I mean, obviously,
I have no idea what the hell happens after we die,
but to go back to kind of what I was saying earlier about
the scientific fact that we are eternal.
That the things that make me what I am,
and I mean like the cells in my body, the atoms,
the sort of most base structure
of what has created this body is eternal, is forever.
Those things don't just go away,
they become something else.
Matter and energy is forever.
So that means my cells, my atoms, they are forever,
they don't just stop being, they just stop being me.
But I am more than just this physical body,
whether you believe in a soul or not,
you believe in consciousness.
A lot of philosophers, a lot of theologians will say,
your consciousness is your soul,
stop thinking of them as different things.
That your ability to say, I am me,
is you recognizing and communing with what is your soul.
Whatever consciousness is,
and we don't know is involved in our biological processes.
So I guess what I am saying is when I die,
all the things that make up my material self
continue forever, that's science.
The matter continues forever,
the energy continues forever.
Well, if my consciousness is in some ways
the sum of my matter and my energy,
then who's to say my consciousness
doesn't continue forever in some way, shape, or form.
Do you know what I mean?
So when people ask me like,
do you believe in life after death?
That to me is life after death.
That the thing that makes me, me,
continues in some way,
that like my consciousness doesn't disappear
because my consciousness is the result of matter and energy,
and matter and energy doesn't disappear.
And that's very sufi.
Right.
Yeah.
So, the answer is I don't know,
but that's my kind of prevailing theory.
There's a great metaphor in the Bahai writings
that I've talk about in my chapter on death
which is, it's pretty simple.
It's kinda like the bird in the cage one,
it's a little bit,
you might go, that's kind of simple,
but it's also profound.
And that is that when we're a baby in the womb,
we're growing what we need for this physical world.
So we're in floating in this kind of stasis,
growing our bones, our eyelashes,
our ears and lips and eyebrows and elbows and everything
that we're gonna need.
The baby has no idea why it's growing elbows.
If you ask the baby, interview the baby,
what's up with the elbows?
Baby like, I have no idea,
I'm sitting in this amniotic sack, I'm fine,
I'm connected with my mother.
It's all good, I don't need elbows.
But then there's this very scary event
of like going through the birth canal.
I'm like, oh shit this whole experience is coming to an end.
This is terrifying, there's blood,
there's pain, there's discomfort,
But what an incredible world we get born into.
You get to kind of-
You get to see Picasso paintings
and you get to have parties and you get to fall in love
and there's all kinds of new experiences await you.
Well, the same thing happens.
So I don't know what happens when we die,
but I think metaphorically speaking,
we are like the death doula might say,
we are being born into a new experience
and that, what we're growing in this world
are not physical arms and legs,
we're growing spiritual arms and legs and elbows.
Yeah.
We're growing patience,
and kindness and humility and compassion,
and love and honesty.
And these qualities that are kind of
"Higher qualities but qualities of light."
Those are what we take with us
when we're plunged through that painful, difficult,
bloody, difficult, painful birth canal of death
into this other reality.
I love that.
There's also something beautiful about wonder
and not knowing the answer
that I think gives our lives a level of richness.
Like if we could know everything,
is that something that we should aspire to?
And or is it even possible to know everything?
Is it possible to answer that question with certitude,
what happens after death?
And if we could answer it, should we?
What does it mean to drift between
this life and the afterlife?
Are there personal or universal truths
to be gleaned from those who have survived
a near death experience?
Well, my conversation with ultra runner Tommy Rivs,
shines a light on these questions
as he unpacks the particular spiritual awareness
that he gleaned as a result of the coma he endured
for several months.
I hope you find this experience as profound
and as enlightening as I did.
What was that-
Like where do you think he went?
Like paint that picture for me of being in that in between.
Oh gosh.
There was exhaustion,
I think is the overwhelming feeling that I felt initially.
And it was that I was trying so hard to stay here.
I could sense that something was pulling me.
And it was painful, it was uncomfortable.
I was trying really, really hard to not leave
whatever this was.
Trying to be held by my body still.
And then I remember there was a time
where I was just so tired,
just so, so tired.
And I remember thinking, I don't wanna do this anymore,
I don't think I can do this anymore.
And by then I'd lost any recollection
that I had a life here.
I didn't remember that I had kids,
I didn't remember that I lived in Flagstaff,
any of it.
And there was a point where-
The weird thing is that Steph was always with me
the entire time.
I thought we were on this just grand adventure,
that we were exploring the cosmos together.
And I got to a point where,
it's gonna be hard,
I stopped-
I made the conscious decision that I was gonna be done,
that I didn't wanna fight
whatever was pulling me away anymore,
that I didn't have the strength to fight anymore.
And there was a sense of peace
and just comfort in wherever it was that I was going.
And I saw it,
and it was inviting and beautiful and safe.
And Steph nudged me and she said,
"You've gotta go back."
I said, I don't wanna go back, like, look at this place.
I said, Come with me, just come with me.
Like, don't you wanna be here too?
And she grabbed my face and turned my head.
I said, I don't want to go back.
She said, You don't have a choice.
And she pointed,
and I could see in the distance my girls
and I'd forgotten that they even existed.
She said, you don't have a choice,
you've got those three little girls
that you've gotta go home to.
I remember seeing it
and being so angry.
Just because I felt like,
I don't know how I'm gonna do this.
I don't have the strength to go back, I'm so done.
I'm so ready to just stop fighting whatever this is.
I remember just closing my eyes and breathing
and just kind of just accepting.
It was like, okay, you know I guess I don't have a choice,
I guess I have to come back.
And then the pull,
all of that fighting that I had done
to stay where I had been initially,
it was the same amount of effort to come back.
Hmm, but this idea,
like the mysteries of consciousness
when you're in a comatose state-
Yeah.
is fascinating.
And you have this, basically near death experience
that you recollect with incredible clarity.
Yeah.
The idea that you had awareness-
In that liminal space is fascinating.
And coming out of that,
and now with some time and distance
between that experience and where you're at now,
like what do you make of that?
Like spiritually?
Yeah.
Like that's a trip.
Right, yeah.
I don't see it in any way as though like,
oh, I discovered the truth.
I had this vision, I had this experience,
and this is the experience that you have.
I don't feel that way at all.
It was the experience that I had.
But I remember,
we continue, it's not just darkness,
it doesn't just end.
And it's right here.
It's all happening right here,
but it's, it's different.
I remember realizing that, okay,
if I become one mode from this body,
I can't go back and I will still be here, right here.
All of this will still be happening,
but I won't have the ability to communicate
with everybody who's still in that space.
And I remember thinking how agonizing that would be
to see my girls and that they would still be right here,
but I wouldn't be able to communicate to 'em.
I wouldn't be able to let them know-
But you have awareness of the other dimension.
But also complete awareness of all of their fear
and all of their questions
and all of their grief and all of their hurting.
And being able to see it and feel all of it,
but not be able to reach across and say,
but I'm still right here.
Just so you know I'm still right here.
Wow.
And that was-
The fear of that was a huge motivator.
I remember also thinking and feeling and seeing
that heaven and hell,
they exist, but they exist to everybody simultaneously.
And they exist in proportion
of the amount of love that we gave
and the amount of love that we were able to receive.
And then the hell part
is the recollection and the understanding of all of the love
that we didn't give and didn't receive when we could have.
And that heaven and hell exists simultaneously
based off of the different relationships
that we had while we had the opportunity
to express those things.
And that there could be a sense of heaven,
such a big term,
but a sense of peace
with the way that we conducted ourselves
with a certain individual.
And the complete opposite was an awareness
of the way that we conducted ourselves with somebody else.
And that it's all connected.
That it all continues.
And that-
Gosh, just the urgency of now.
That what we continue to feel beyond this
is directly linked with
the way that we interact with people-
comport ourselves.
while we're here.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean, that's so powerful.
There is not this idealistic future
somewhere down the line
where we're gonna find happiness.
Where happiness exists there
and we're going to be happy.
That we we're gonna get there
and everything's gonna be right,
and we're gonna have this sense of just contentment
and rest and ease.
It's like, that doesn't exist.
It's right now.
It's all happening this very moment.
It's the choice that you make about
how to experience your life moment to moment.
The heaven and hell.
Heaven and hell are all happening,
all the time to all of us.
The entire range of human emotions, experiences,
all of that is happening to us all the time.
And whether or not we experience that joy, that happiness
is based on our ability to see it as it's happening,
rather than in retrospect.
Rather than looking back and saying,
oh, okay, I was happy.
I didn't realize it, but I was,
things were really good back then.
Those were the good old days.
We don't ever realize that until after the fact.
And our ability to have joy,
to have happiness, to be happy,
is 100% based on our capacity
to see it as it's happening.
When we investigate what it means
to have a spiritual life,
to live a spiritual life,
to pursue a spiritual life,
we can benefit from learning concrete principles
by which to live.
Enter Raghunath Cappo
a punk rock Vanguard who walked away
from a successful music career to dawn the robes of a monk.
In this final clip, Raghunath Cappo takes us through
six very practical codes for living
distilled from the ancient teachings
of a renowned Indian scholar and mystic
that when practiced are extremely valuable.
So what is the process of rewiring that?
Like when you go to the ashram
and you start living as a monk,
what is the teaching like,
what is the day to day existence
where you start to intuit these teachings
and put them into practice?
Well, there's a lot to share.
I'm working on a book right now
that extracted six very powerful principles
that I taught from the teachings.
And the first one is,
and these are based on the teachings of Chaitanya Mahaprabhu
who was a great,
considered by some as a child prodigy,
'cause he was a child prodigy in Sanskrit.
Some other people that knew him more intimately
thought of that he was a mystic,
'cause he performed so many mystical things,
Christ like mysticism.
But his intimate followers who are great gurus
in their own right, they considered him an avatar.
So his teachings were very simple.
And one of them is very basic
and it's a great takeaway.
And if you wanna take away anything from today,
you can take this way,
stop criticizing other people.
The sound coming out of your mouth can be toxic.
And that was a powerful thing.
Stop criticizing.
And I realize I'm living with so much criticism in my mind.
That doesn't mean we should throw discernment out,
we need discernment.
But the condemning language that happens on a regular basis
from finding fault with other people
and how you would do things so much better
if you were doing them, cut it out.
Stop letting that pour outta your mouth.
That's a big one.
If you want, I'll just run through these things.
Yeah, let's do it now.
This is great.
That's one.
And first of all, when did this guy live?
Like that 1400-
Same time Columbus was showing up here.
This person Chaitanya Mahaprabhu was in Bengal
and traveled throughout India.
And basically it was a renaissance of Bhakti.
Bhakti means-
Bhakti yoga means connecting to source through love,
that's all the word really means.
And so a lot of the practices are singing,
are cooking, are meditation, but everything is an action.
Like you're acting in a loving way.
It's dealing with other people.
So yeah, this is one of the teachings I call-
The book is called "The Six Pillars of Bhakti."
And so one is not criticizing,
the second one is being tolerant.
Whereas criticism deals with other people,
and another one is just dealing with life situation
and stop blaming the world for your unhappiness.
And this is very powerful, it's transformational.
Even if you're a materialist,
this main teaching can transform your life.
But if you want to really experience
like the higher echelons of meditation,
it's gotta be there.
Criticism, tolerance.
And this isn't a huge one, number three.
And if you could add this one to your life,
it's just such a game changer.
It's, I take no offense,
meaning I will not be offended on a regular basis.
And that's a very common thing.
Sometimes we could see somebody talking over there
and I get offended.
I think they're talking about me.
So without provocation,
I think someone's got something against me.
And sometimes will walk around
holding some resentment for a person
who didn't even mean anything.
And that gets split in two things,
'cause sometimes people don't mean anything
but due to some proclivity that I have,
that I don't trust the world,
that I take an offense
and I carry that resentment around with me-
Yeah.
And it becomes a burden.
But sometimes people have hurt me,
they've actually deliberately hurt me.
But still that desire
or that need to forgive has to be there
because in the bhakti culture
is nothing's actually happening to me,
it's happening for me,
that there's a benevolent energy lifting us
higher and higher and higher.
And we have to see that everything is for my edification,
for my purification and sometimes even tragic things.
And so there's a firm faith
that everything's happening for me.
Now we shouldn't be heartless
when it comes to someone else's suffering.
I should see, okay, he's having a hard time.
We should feel like I have to reach out to that person,
they're having a hard time.
But for my own situation,
I should feel like,
I'm going through a hard time
and this must be for my benefit.
What is that benefit?
And I can look at life like that.
So we don't hold any resentment,
we don't criticize, we're tolerant.
Next one, we see the good in others and we let them know it.
Find good, and this is where we're talking about,
instead of finding what this person's doing so wrong,
what are they doing right?
Why are they good?
This is such a powerful practice in this day and age,
because otherwise we're gonna lock in
and we're just gonna foster hate with others.
And we're gonna have no commonality whatsoever.
What do we have in common?
What is right about this person?
And it's such a great thing.
Truthfully, it's a marriage saver,
it's a relationship saver.
What is good about this person
and then sharing it with them.
Telling them why I appreciate you.
And that lack of appreciation can really kill,
it can kill love quick.
I mean, isn't that what romance is,
is full 100% appreciation for that person.
Right, and the second piece about letting that person know
is crazy powerful.
Right.
And it's something that most of us don't do
nearly enough of.
I mean, we might have a person
that would do anything for us.
They would come anywhere at any time, at any moment.
Hey, I need your help, can you come here? Yeah.
That person, I never let them know
how much I appreciate them.
Sometimes the people that are the closest to us,
we never share with them
how much we appreciate them.
Right.
And in you recounting these lessons,
I'm thinking this should be
the terms and conditions on Twitter.
Like what if before you could log onto Twitter,
you had to read through these sort of guidelines,
or sort of guideposts for how to behave or acquit yourself.
Because everything that you just shared is so anathema
to the way that we conduct ourselves
in the kind of public conversations
that are happening on social media.
And we're all seeing the fractures,
the fishers that are are starting to expand
in the fabric of our society.
Like we're no longer able to productively communicate
in a healthy way,
and it's because we've lost sight
of these very things that allow us to remember
that we are truly one.
And no one's happy.
They're all sad.
Even if they're righteous,
they're just like sad in their righteousness
of their rightness.
Anyway, that's see the good in others let them know it.
The appreciation is such a powerful,
it's powerful in this world
and it's powerful in the spiritual realm as well.
That's why I love this stuff
because it's relevant, it's real.
It's not just like, when I die, I'll go to heaven.
Who cares?
I don't know about heaven.
I don't know anything about heaven.
I don't even know if it's real.
But I do know these are very, very practical in this life
for my own personal joy, my own personal integrity,
my relationships.
You were saying like, yeah,
people in Twitter should learn this.
The reason why I sort of like
extracted these from the teachings,
because I was taking groups,
every year I take a group on pilgrimage.
This year I'm going to Nepal.
It's sort of like, you would like it.
You should go.
You go to these various
like spiritual sites all over the world?
Spiritual sites all over the world.
So this year we're going trekking through Nepal in April.
Wow.
And so half the time is trekking and then holy places.
Nepal is like an old part of Indian kingdom.
One of the Indian kingdoms,
they preserved a lot of the ancient Hindu texts,
the Buddhist texts.
And it's got whatever, 1300 Himalayan peaks.
Wow.
We gonna do day hiking
half the time.
When are you doing that?
April, come.
Wow.
It'd be great.
That's tempting.
But Keep going.
And we do India every year which is also great.
And we go to holy places.
But you're bringing a bunch of people to India
who've never been to a third world country
and we're traveling together and they're not used to it,
and it's a little shocking sometimes.
So I've really set up these six pillars
as sort of behavior, sort of guardrails.
This is what we do, we don't criticize.
And it's sort of a contract we mentally sign.
I read them over every day.
This is what we're doing,
we're not gonna criticize,
we're not gonna find fault,
we're not gonna be resentful,
and we're gonna find the good in others,
we're gonna let them know it.
The next one was quick to apologize.
If you feel like you hurt someone's feeling,
if you're a little obtuse,
you apologize first.
You say, Hey, I'm sorry,
I don't know if that offended you,
but please forgive me if it did.
Mm-hmm.
A big game changer.
And another one is we keep a tally
of how we are blessed.
We keep a list of how fortunate we are.
A gratitude practice basically.
What's that?
A gratitude practice.
And sometimes people don't have a gratitude practice.
They have a, this is unfair practice,
this is why,
or an entitlement practice.
Yeah.
And the problem with that is, it's simple math,
entitlement makes you sad, gratitude makes you happy.
If you feel like the world owes you everything,
you're always gonna be miserable.
There's never enough the world can owe you.
This architecture is not that different from 12 Step.
And I know you've got this Bhakti 12 step recovery program.
I wanna spend a little bit of time talking about this
because there's a lot of similarities,
like do a personal inventory,
hold yourself accountable,
take the next right action,
make your amends, practice gratitude.
All of these things are endemic to recovery
and are applicable to humanity at large.
This is not like just something that
alcoholics and drug addicts need to
figure out a way to master.
Because truth is for everyone and no one owns it
and no one's got a monopoly on it.
Yeah.
And there's people,
Bill Wilson, they're like inspired.
There's somehow inspired
and they've got their receiver on.
Just like right now there's like radio waves in this room,
but we don't have our receivers on.
We can't pick up the ham radio receivers
or the channels from France
or the channels from the country Western station.
But when you have that receiver,
you can start picking up, up all.
When you start to fine tune your radar into spiritual truth,
not for your ego,
if you tune in with your ego and spiritual truth,
you'll find your little group that hates, that finds others,
but you won't find commonality and connection.
It'll be just another way for your ego
to live out in the name of I'm better than.
And we find that in any type of,
I mean, come on, like I said, I'm a cult aficianado.
I found it when I was a raw foodist,
I found it as local farmer growing straight edge-
You can always find people who are into things.
You find it in politics,
you definitely find it in religion,
that if I'm doing something for myself betterment,
I shouldn't become more hateful.
If I'm becoming more hateful,
I think I'm doing something wrong.
I sincerely hope that after hearing
all of these amazing perspectives on spirituality,
that you find yourself with an open heart,
armed with new practices that can elevate your thinking
and behavior toward a more spiritual consciousness
and ultimately a more fulfilled life.
If you have been inspired,
then consider visiting the full in-depth conversations
with these esteemed guests.
You can find the links to each episode
posted in the description below
or in the show notes on richroll.com.
Thanks for listening and watching,
and please know that I'm wishing all of you
the greatest spiritual life possible.
Until next time, peace.
Thanks.
(upbeat instrumental music)